io
ho fatto un gozzo in questo stento e
lombi entrati mi sono nella patch e
fotte il cool per contrappeso groppa la
mia pittura morta difende ormai giovanni
e il mio onore
non sento il logo bon negli eau pittore
siamo a roma
siamo nei primi anni del cinquecento a
scrivere e michelangelo
si tratta di uno dei suoi sonetti forse
più famoso dedicato all'amico giovanni
da pistoia sta parlando di una delle
pitture più famose dell'intero mondo sta
parlando di un momento in cui si trovava
nella cappella sistina in grande
difficoltà non riuscivo a portarla
avanti quel lavoro pensateci
pensateci bene quando non so in un
vostro lavoro
credete di aver fatto insomma di essere
contenti soddisfatti
pensateci pensate a michelangelo
ispiratevi a lui che di fronte a quello
non era soddisfatto per nulla
immaginatevelo al buio nella nella
penombra a testa all'ingiù a dipingere
con il pennello che gocciolava colore
sulla barba
immaginatelo con schiena in arquata così
come si è rappresentato in questo
schizzo di lato al suo netto che lo
stesso ha redatto insomma durano questo
questi versi io li ho letti per la prima
volta che avevo 18 anni faccio
l'istituto d'arte e devo dire che mi
hanno insegnato tanto già allora un
qualcosa che poi ho portato avanti nel
nel mio mestiere perché questi questi
versi ci dicono
innanzitutto che la perfezione per
carità sarà di un altro mondo
ok però il desiderio di raggiungerla
quello no quello è tutto terreno ma ci
dicono anche un'altra cosa ci raccontano
di una persona che se si sentiva un
genio lo era lo era definito dagli altri
e che però si metteva tutto se stesso
per andare avanti la fatica l'ossessione
l'irrequietezza insoddisfatta
ecco è così che si raggiungono davvero i
successi
spostiamoci di un secolo all'incirca e
non so se voi siete passati ma è là
davanti spero vivamente di sì siamo a
firenze quella della basilica di santa
maria novella fu progettata nel
quattrocento da leon battista alberti
avete mai sentito parlare di alberti
alla fine una persona un personaggio
piuttosto famoso almeno a scuola
dovreste averlo incontrato qualcuno di
voi potrebbe dirmi alberti sì ho sentito
era quello umanista lì quello che
traduceva i classici quanto dirà no no
non era lui
alberti era il teorico dell'arte quello
che ha scritto per primo un trattato
sulla vettura è iniziato a ragionare sul
metodo quando nessuno prima di lui aveva
fatto che ha ripreso l'antico anche in
quello un altro potrebbe dire no no è
l'architetto l'architetto quello che ha
fatto quella veroli ma che ha costruito
fatto costruire che ha progettato
edifici a mantova a rimini a roma
altrove
tutti quanti avreste ragione è un
poligrafo era una persona a tutto tondo
faceva tante cose insieme
quello che magari sfugge quello che
magari non si sa è
quello che faceva all'inizio della
propria carriera
chiamiamola così alberti per vivere
perché perché praticamente lui scriveva
brevi per conto del papa ora che cosa
sono i brevi sono delle lettere
apostoliche sono carte di cancelleria
amministrativa
mutatis mutandis quello che possiamo
dire che alberti faceva quello che fanno
un po oggi nelle segreterie facevano
amministrativo
ora l'attenzione è distanza storica
questa non è una novità io vela porto
qui chissà che sta succedendo una cosa
che molti umanisti facevano erano
comunque anche cortigiani in qualche
modo il punto è un altro
il punto è che alberti non era felice e
lo scrisse lo scrisse in delle lettere
del quattrocento inviate a dei colleghi
a degli amici e si lamentava dell'esilio
della sua famiglia lui firenze la vide
solo dopo quando il rinascimento era
scoppiato quando masaccio aveva dipinto
la cappella brancacci quando
brunelleschi aveva fatto la cupola
assist all'inaugurazione della cupola
insieme al papà alberti prima non era
così in auge possiamo dire e allora in
queste lettere scriveva della gente
corrotta dei cardinali delle persone
oblique che andavano al dall'uni
chiedevano prebende favori
il pro missioni
e non era contento e ancora si lamentava
delle lungaggini della burocrazia
ora altre cose che se le mettiamo
insieme no ci dicono qualcosa anche oggi
diciamo il potere le dinamiche del
potere quelle cambiano nel corso dei
secoli alcune cose non mutano mai ora
anche queste lettere e niente un bravo
insegnante all'istituto d'arte io le
lessi a scuola e anche queste furono
importanti molto più importanti di quel
sonetto di michelangelo se posso dire
perché questa cosa questa lamentela di
uno come lui ci dice tanto e ci dice un
qualcosa che anche i precedenti speaker
più o meno hanno sfiorato chi sei cosa
ti rappresenta tutto nella vita sei
quello che hai studiato si è studiato
oppure quello per cui è passione non sei
sempre ciò che ti dà da vivere non sei
il tuo lavoro non è così che ti può
capitare di dover fare tante cose
diverse per sbarcare il lunario che non
sempre basta la bravura quella di cui
sopra voglia di gran gelo no vuole anche
fortuna
tanta fortuna affinché i pianeti si
allineino in qualche modo affinché il
treno passi organi passa però deve
essere lì ad aspettarlo e non sulle
rotaie finita ora questa questa cosa me
la sono portata avanti nei lunghi anni
sono giovane però insomma il precariato
ognuno vita molto a modo suo
negli anni del precariato quando era
dall'altra parte della barricata quando
c'era da pagare le bollette quando c'era
da pagare l'affitto e lo spiraglio non
c'era c'era una borsa c'era una cosa a
quell'altra mi ricordavo di queste
lettere quello dice lui di altre cose
che ti ho letto e andavo avanti e oggi
ancora le uso adesso che è stato qui che
non ha questi problemi per valutare chi
mi viene davanti a chi devo insegnare
cosa devo dire
l'inserimento questo cioè siete quello
che volete fare quello per cui avete
passione quello che
punto anche perché questa cosa se ti
dice male finisce la farai nel tempo
libero non per lavoro ma ciò non cambia
la tua essenza ecco per rispondere al
primo speaker i sei quello che vuoi fare
secondo me che poi può cambiare nel
corso degli anni è né può essere
soddisfatto mi presento io sono lo
capezzuto che mi ha presentato anche
riccardo prima insegna letteratura
artistica ossia le parole degli umanisti
intorno all'arte le parole degli
artefici intorno alla tecnica le parole
degli artisti intorno a se stessi e
queste sono le parole che ho provato in
qualche modo a portarvi oggi attraverso
due esempi celeberrimi però attenzione
perché questa cosa un po rischiosa da
fare soprattutto al di fuori della
accademia non si creda che è possibile
in qualche modo rendere contemporaneo
quello che contemporaneo non è non è
così il mestiere dello storico non è
appiattire il mestiere dello storico e
dare a chi ascolta chi legge a chi
studia gli strumenti per capire un'altra
cosa una cosa che è lontana anni luce
chi è venuto prima di noi che ha un
sistema di valori diverso che ha un
approccio alla vita diverso che a
credenze religiose differenti
oggi è giustamente si fa caso a dire
buongiorno a tutti e tutte lo vedeste
mai in una lettera del quattrocento
no per questo motivo interpreteremmo con
la contemporaneità è il paradigma del
non essere inclusiva una lettera del
quattrocento no io sono vegetariano
esempio ho studiato per anni un pittore
si chiamava cola dell'amatrice ho
studiato il suo taccuino di disegni
all'interno del taccuino di disegni
aveva tutta una serie di letta
scusate diretta da tutta una serie di
appunti dove praticamente raccontava
come farsi diamo un etico gli organi
genitali dei cani non avrei dovuto
studiarlo etica rispetto per gli animali
si inorridisce benvenuto cellini era uno
stupratore
se lo ragioniamo con i canoni attuali
questa distanza è importantissima
altro esempio giovanni da capestrano il
santo per conoscere c'è l'enciclopedia
antisemita giovanni da capestrano è
interpretato come antisemita
dall'enciclopedia in un momento in cui
non c'è l'antisemitismo gene capestrano
ha fatto cose brutte mar antigiudaico
era un altro tempo c'era stato il
nazismo di mezzo e antigiudaico come lo
era shakespeare come lo era paolo
uccello che ha dipinto il martirio di
una famiglia di ebrei per recuperare una
scena religiosa della distanza la
distanza è importantissima del resto mi
permetto un consiglio di lettura per chi
non ha avuto ancora modo di farlo
citando marguerite yourcenar memorie di
adriano libro strepitoso scrittrice
magnifica lei cosa dice ad un certo
punto anche a plutarco sfuggirà sempre
alessandro figuratevi se noi non
sfuggono michelangelo alberti
insomma poi certo questo è il contato il
contatto con il passato in realtà quello
che faccio io per lavoro l'insegnante il
professore il contatto vero e nel
presente il contatto è con gli studenti
fondamentalmente e a proposito di
frustrazione perché mi sembra di aver
detto qualcosa di contemporaneo
citandovi dei brani degli stralci di
queste scritture da artisti perché il
gallino neanche si evince il sistema di
valori diversa riesce un sentimento la
frustrazione non sono contenti non sono
soddisfatti oggi dopo due anni di
pandemia cos'è la frustrazione forse lo
cambiamo un poco tutti
e a proposito di frustrazione forse è il
caso di tornarci in presenza
all'università altrove sono stufo di
stare 9 ore davanti allo schermo a fare
ricevimento a fare
esami a fare farla reale le persone così
adesso ci siamo riusciti non era colpa
nostra
l'emergenza però rendiamoci conto
dell'importanza del tornare di fronte
sono bellissimi questi mezzi
però insomma bisogna tenere conto anche
di tutto il resto va da concludere ora o
intanto nel presente e insegnamento
io penso che chiunque di voi a qualunque
livello ha incontrato almeno una volta
nella vita
qualcuno che da dietro la cattedra ha
cambiato il suo modo di vedere le cose
attenzione in positivo o in negativo è
perché se poi qualcuno e magari la vita
ha provato a rovinare la una nota una
sospensione io ho rischiato di essere
bocciato professore che non gli piaceva
e ha sospeso rischia di non essere qui
però poi ho incontrato un altro che
invece ha creduto ma è proprio lo stesso
anno è affatto cena insieme a tante
altre cose io sia qui l'importanza di
questo contatto è determinante
io alla fine di ogni polso faccio un po
un bilancio che so adottata una
bibliografia magari nuova l'hanno
recepita l'hanno capita funziona
quanti erano all'inizio che ha mollato
perché ha mollato kim ha chiesto la tesi
non perché voglia le tesi assolutamente
però è un servizio dobbiamo dare
sembreranno di meno forse ho sbagliato
qualcosa
questo te lo devi chiedere quando fai
questo mestiere alla fine però penso e
credo che tu sei lì e se anche solo uno
studente una studentessa oltre a
imparare qualcosa magari prima hanno
insegnato mio sono stato segnato prima
aveva forse posso andare a dormire un po
più contento perché forse il mio
mestiere in qualche modo diciamo le ho
fatto portato a casa la pagnotta
e allora concludiamo con michelangelo e
vi andiamo a monte con un anticlimax ora
che cosa è questa migrando pochi anni
dopo gli affreschi della volta si mise a
dipingere il giudizio universale altro
dipinto strepitoso il cristo giudice
violento la madonna spaventata rivestiti
da un pittore
volterra per altro amico di milan gela
chievo che siano al brachetto né perché
gli al dovuti coprire perché perché
michelangelo vivo queste pittore non
erano erano considerate licenziose da
pietro aretino che aveva litigato con
michelangelo perché non era stato
ascoltato sul programma iconografico e
pietro aretino allora scriverà una
lettera contro di lui mentre prima ne
collezionava disegni poi ci saranno
altri teologi la controriforma criticare
miei arancio vabbè lasciamo perdere
però questa cosa ci dice che il modo di
vedere le cose cambia e allora su questo
concludiamo davvero michelangelo quello
di cui sopra quello di cui abbiamo
parlato più grande pittore forse tra
tutti del suo tempo e più grande
scultore perché due vittorie appunto non
si definiva alla fine del cinquecento
passa da roma per la cappella sistina
un altro vettore un pittore che
consideriamo titoli 21 spagnola in
realtà poi tornato in spagna di seta
toledo e lavora tantissimo e parla con
il suocero di de las cats delle pitture
di michelangelo e gli dice ma è un po in
ombra che non sapevi in terra ora fino a
qui tutto bene
il fatto è che quel pittore si toledo ok
però risiedeva lì non era di lì era nato
a creta era passato da venezia era sceso
a roma aveva lavorato per i farnese
aveva un cognome impronunciabile però
era soprannominato el greco praticamente
uno dei massimi artisti del suo tempo in
europa
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non è